Yeah,
hey everyone,
we're going to be doing something a
little different this week.
I've got my new eyes jumping on a skype
call shortly.
He and Sam Harris or cough.
There is a new book about Islam and
Maajid is a former Islamic extremist
himself.
A ton of you guys have been asking us to
sit down,
but he lives in London,
so we thought we'd give the skype thing
a shot.
Actually,
he's in New York at the moment.
I saw a picture of him and Morgan
Freeman in a mosque yesterday,
so I'm going to ask him about that and
much more in a little bit,
but first let's do a little
housekeeping.
I want to talk about some of the
principles we laid out in the first
episode and some of the reaction to last
week show.
It seems that a bunch of you weren't
thrilled with my guest.
Jimmy.
Jimmy is a hardcore lefty progressive
and uses some of the tactics I mentioned
that I wouldn't be using on the show.
First,
let me just say that I can only hold
myself to the rules that I laid out if I
stopped and mentioned saying every time
a guest said,
saying that goes against my personal
rules,
the show would be incredibly slow and
horrifically painful.
More importantly,
as we build a community based on
tolerance and other ideas,
it's important that we remain tolerant
of ideas we don't like.
Jimmy is a great friend of mine.
We've worked together on air for years.
We've done standup gigs together and
I've had him and his wife over for
dinner numerous times.
Yeah,
we don't agree on everything,
including some pretty big issues,
but I think life is about more than just
scoring who is right on everything all
the time.
The most interesting part of last week's
response was that some people said the
episode was an echo chamber and I didn't
push back enough.
Other people question why I even had
people I disagree with on at all,
and that's the beauty of the Internet,
right?
We can all be part of the same exact
conversation and still see it through
our individual prisons.
Good journalism is the search for truth.
This show will be a battle of ideas,
not just having our own ideas
reinforced,
you know,
there's so much intolerance of the other
on both sides and I think we can create
something that's so much better than
that.
Actually,
I don't just think it.
I know it because I see it already
happening.
Last week I had a hardcore progressive
lefty.
This week I have a former Islamic
extremists turned moderate,
trying to reform his religion.
Next week I have a gay conservative from
Breitbart,
Milo Yiannopoulos.
I won't agree with all of them all the
time,
but I most likely won't shout them down
either.
I have enough faith in you guys that if
we have an honest conversation here,
the truth will present itself.
This of course,
reminds me of the Galactic Republic.
In the early days of the death star,
grandma tarkin wanted to stifle debate
because they had the most powerful super
laser in the universe.
Of course,
let's not forget that darth vader said
that the death star was nothing compared
to the power of the force.
The force is on our side.
Let's use it wisely.
Alright.
So much and thanks for doing this.
We've been going back and forth for,
for months now.
I've only had to show up for,
for three weeks,
but we've been going back and forth for
awhile.
And uh,
you're in New York right now?
Uh,
you live,
you live in London,
correct?
That's right.
Yeah.
So you live in London,
so you're halfway between a Los Angeles
and London.
So I figured we'd do the skype because I
don't know when you're gonna be out
here.
Any,
any La plans coming?
I don't know.
I'd love to come to La and I was good
friends in,
uh,
on the west coast,
but nothing fixed yet.
So it's good to have this opportunity.
Yeah.
All right,
so we'll do the skype thing with you in
New York and La.
So first off I saw a picture of you that
you tweeted yesterday you were hanging
out with Morgan Freeman in a mosque.
So what,
what was that about?
Yes.
This is what's brought me here to a New
York icon.
Explain too much of it at the moment.
All I can say is that I had a great
conversation with him in the,
uh,
in the Islamic center of,
of New York.
Uh,
we spent a good hour or so having a chat
about the distinctions between Islam and
Islamism and,
uh,
about my story and the work I do.
Um,
but beyond that we're just going to have
to wait and see what else I'm to.
All right,
well now he's played God.
So I guess he's the right guy to talk to
on that
in,
in the house of God.
I was speaking to a man that played God
about God.
Alright,
there you go.
Okay.
So,
uh,
I want to talk to you about some of the
things that you probably did speak with
him that.
So first,
let's just start with your story because
your,
your biography,
what you've lived through to get to here
is really,
really incredible.
So can you just sort of sum that up in a
couple minutes,
those who want the,
as you know,
the full story.
It's in my memoir called radical.
Um,
but,
but in a,
in a summarized form,
basically I joined a revolutionary Islam
is group at the age of 16 years old.
Uh,
I ended up on the leadership of this
organization and spent 13 years with
them and I played my role in exporting
this organization from Britain to
Pakistan and then to Denmark and
eventually to Egypt.
The group's name was his,
had.
It was the first among these limits
groups to popular reaction of
resurrecting a caliphate that would seek
to conquer other countries and enforce
their version of Islam as low.
And,
uh,
the method by which they aimed to come
to power was by a military coups.
So we are very much focused in
recruiting army officers to join our
organization and then inciting them
towards military coups.
And that's what took me to Pakistan is
what eventually took me to Egypt.
I arrived one day before the nine slash
11 attacks.
And then 10 months later I found myself
arrested and detained and taken to the
torture dungeons of Egypt,
stir state security headquarters in
Cairo.
And then sentenced after four months in
solitary confinement.
Sentenced to five years in prison.
As a political prisoner,
that's at that point is when Amnesty
International adopted me as a prisoner
of conscience,
uh,
began campaigning for my release because
of course,
no,
we had views that I now find repugnant
and what described as extreme,
uh,
we were and we had a group still is non
non terrorist,
which is why it's still illegal in
America and across across Europe.
So it's,
it's the distinction I draw between an
Islamist group and a jihadist group is
that if Islam,
Islam is the desire to impose any
interpretation of Islam over society,
a jihadism is the use of force to spread
Islam,
Islam and uh,
and,
and jihadist terrorism is the use of
force to spread Islam Islam by targeting
civilians.
Um,
the group that I joined wasn't.
Islam is group.
It wasn't a jihadist group.
Right.
So I'm glad you made that distinction
because I do find that when we're having
this conversation and it's being had by
so many different people in so many
different forms that just the
definitions alone are lost.
And I know you've done a lot of work
trying to just explain that kind of
stuff to people so they're able to
understand what we're talking about
here.
Yeah,
positive.
The problem is because this is a
phenomenon that we've never really dealt
with before in terms of human beings
have never really dealt with this
phenomenon of a,
of ideological Islam seeking a,
uh,
a very bolshevik form of control,
totalitarian control over society.
We simply as,
as,
as people didn't have the lexicon to
have these conversations.
So though I use the definitions,
you won't find these definitions,
tolton universities or in academic tomes
because people will dealt with the
problem before.
So part of the challenge that we faced
was in coming up with very crystal clear
logical definitions and then
popularizing them.
Uh,
and so you often,
you'll find that I repeat myself a lot
and the reason I repeat myself is
because,
you know,
uh,
we have to popularize these terms into
popularize.
These concepts can only come through
repetition until everyone finally begins
to understand.
And it got to a point where the prime
minister of the UK understood.
So we got somewhere.
Okay,
so you spent about five years in an
Egyptian prison now that was under
Mubarak at the time,
who technically,
I suppose he was known as the president,
but he basically was a dictator that was
backed by the US for about 30 years.
What?
What was that like being in an Egyptian
prison?
I can't imagine.
Well,
it wasn't a pleasant experience at all
to the torture.
First of all,
for the first four days and then we will
put into solitary confinement for four
months and I was held in a cell as well.
All of us are in that period of solitary
confinement cells where in which we had
no sanitation,
no lights,
no,
no beds.
We had nothing but a bad concrete cell
in which to a English to try and get
through without,
without going insane.
And so I have with me actually I wanted
to show you this because I had a.
When I was arrested I had a pocket sized
version of the Koran,
which is this in my hand here.
This,
this particular Koran has been with me
from the day of my wrist all the way
through the torture dungeons through the
solitary confinement.
Wow.
Um,
and then through through the four years
in prison and,
and one of the things I did is in the
solitary confinement,
we didn't have any.
I need light to read a or anything so
and obviously the mind can wander in
that sort of situation and you fear for
your own sanity.
So one of the things I would do is stand
by the,
by the door of the,
uh,
of the jail cell has looked for the wait
for the light to seep in through the
bars.
And then I would stand there and read,
if you can see is a very small text is
actually tiny now.
Wow.
You,
I would read that.
I ended up memorizing half of it.
I'm sort of in my jail cell,
but it was,
you know,
it was these sorts of things and it's
why I've kept it seals these sorts of
things that kept me from going a not
during the solitary confinement period.
And another thing I want to show you is
this,
this is,
um,
this is a radio which I had with me is,
is a sort of,
it was given to me by the British
embassy and it was actually on this
thing that I heard,
first time that we'd been charged.
We hadn't been informed officially by
the BBC World Service.
I had reported it.
And so I was listening to it on this and
we found out that we,
in fact we'd been charged and then we
would go to trial.
Um,
uh,
and finally,
I think this picture is up on the
Internet when I have the original with
me and this is something I stole from
prison.
Um,
and I've kept it with me ever since
because it meant it means a lot to me.
This is a mug shot that was taken of me
so that,
that's the day,
that's the very day we would drag from
the torture dungeon is to be thrown into
solitary.
So that's before I was actually,
before I was actually put into solitary
confinement.
That's me at 24 years old.
And now you see what you see is my,
uh,
my name in Arabic as you know,
was,
and there is a prison number and uh,
what I've done of course since then is
I've taken that number which is in
Arabic a two,
four,
five,
three,
and I have tattooed on my back as,
as a reminder for me actually have those
days where I've come from a,
which was your original question and the
journey that I've made to get to where I
am now.
Yeah,
it's such an incredible journey.
Uh,
one other thing on the Gel thing,
I find that fascinating that they let
you keep a copy of the Qur'an with you
because wasn't Mubarak basically,
not that he was secular per se,
but they were,
you know,
the Muslim Brotherhood was illegal under
him.
You would think that he would want no
sign of religion to get the prisoners,
uh,
to,
to apprise or something like that.
And yet he let you have it or they will
on the country.
Now,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not about to defend Mubarak.
I cheered when he was overthrown.
It was held in the same cell that he
held me and afterwards,
so I'm not.
I'm not here in any way to defend Hosni
Mubarak.
What I would say is that the Egyptian
dictator and his regime,
I already understood the distinction
that I now make between Islam and
Islamism.
Their problem wasn't us holding copies
of the Koran.
The problem was the interpretation that
we and,
and,
and the ideology of Islam is that I
refer to,
in fact,
they would encourage us to study
traditional medieval Islam because they
knew that medieval Islam wasn't a Islam
Islam,
and they would encourage us to be
exposed to theologians from us how
university we were in prison and that
books so that we could read about Islam
from its medieval era and understand it
wasn't this modern ideological form that
we'd come to adopt.
Now I say this and I say it with a
caveat that of course,
traditional,
ultra conservative medieval Islam also
needs to be reformed.
You know,
it's,
it's the pinnacle.
It's not that of,
you know,
the,
the epitome of,
um,
of civil liberties.
However,
what we,
what we have to accept,
anyone who knows the basic,
the basic thing that most basic thing
about Islamic history and the
development on Islamic theology will
know for all of its faults and there are
plenty of volts by the way.
And fundamentalism largely owes a debt
to sort of the fact that they,
we,
we Muslims generally still revere that
medieval period of our theology and
haven't developed it since,
but it's still very different to what
the Islamists project is and a,
and an Egyptian authorities knew that.
So they would encourage us,
you know,
they would rather we were a conservative
religious or fundamentalist Muslims than
members of the Muslim Brotherhood.
Yeah.
That's so fascinating.
And even if you think about what's going
on with Egypt now,
where we sort of have another version of
Mubarak and CC and sort of controlling
things and yet,
you know,
the Muslim Brotherhood was in charge for
a year and we back them too.
But that,
that,
that's a whole other topic.
So before we move on to some of the
other stuff,
I saw a clip where you were on real time
with Bill Maher from about a year ago
and on the overtime segment you
recounted a story about a bomb maker
that you met in jail.
And I was hoping you could,
you could just sum that up real quick
because I thought,
I thought it was fascinating and it goes
to very much what you're talking about
right now.
Yeah,
sure.
Um,
so in prison that was a,
I mean we were imprisoned with the,
who's who of the John Seeing at the
time.
We had the assassins of.
I'm the oldest of Egypt,
Anwar Sadat who was killed in 1981 group
was known as Tom Freeman,
Jihad.
Those who want to execute.
And in that case were with us in prison.
We have a leader of the Muslim
Brotherhood,
Dr Muhammad and but here has since been
reincarcerated as you mentioned.
Um,
he wasn't the leader of the Brotherhood
at the time.
He became the leader of the Brotherhood,
but he and his entire leadership were
with me in prison.
We have a leadership of his mctivia and
we also had people that came from abroad
and the bomb maker that you refer to a
particular was from doggystyle next door
to Chechnya.
And uh,
they,
uh,
he came via Afghanistan to Egypt and an
attempt to cross that off our crossing
into Gaza to teach us how to make bombs,
but he was caught by the Egyptian
authorities and they imprison them.
They sentenced him to 17 years and I
became friendly with this band and had a
long conversation with him,
uh,
due to the,
to the London bombings because,
you know,
the invasion of Iraq happened when I was
in prison and the London seven slash
seven attacks in London bombings and
sort of the buses and the tubes in
London also happened when I was in
prison.
So I locked it.
I kind of got locked into a long
conversation with this,
with this man about the,
in his view then legitimacy of attacking
London.
And I was attempting to convince him
that it wasn't legitimate.
Now again,
because I used to belong to a non
terrorist yet revolution,
extreme Islamic group.
We didn't believe in jihad isn't input
to come to power,
so we were arguing with jihadists that
actually what they should be focusing on
is a minute recoup.
So that's why I was opposing him,
not I hadn't yet left.
I hadn't yet left Islam is,
and it's because my form of Islam,
Islam in its method have,
you know,
it was very different to his and it's
sort of how it seeks to come to power.
Sure.
But one thing I,
you know,
I'm really proud of is that here's a man
who was trained who was fully capable
of,
uh,
of making bombs and then causing mayhem,
mayhem and havoc yet,
um,
when I put it to him,
that the justification he uses to say
that it's legitimate to target,
but just citizens in that they voted for
their government would be the same
justification one could use for Tux.
So voted for their government in Turkey
is a member of NATO and NATO as an
alliance was involved in Afghanistan.
And so,
and so why wouldn't he be bumping
Turkey?
Um,
and his answer that he,
the answer he gave me was a pragmatic
one.
Not a religious one,
at which point I called him out and I
said,
you see,
so you know,
what you're doing is you're playing
politics,
you're giving me a pragmatic answer,
which is the very thing when Bush does
it,
you criticize Bush for.
Um,
the upshot of that conversation was by
the end of it,
you know,
it took him a couple of days or
whatever.
He knocked on my,
on my jail cell and he came back looking
really sheepish and he said,
you know,
I've been thinking about what you said
and,
uh,
I think you're right though.
I just don't think I agree with you.
It's,
it's not justifying to attack a British
civilians.
And one of the things that really swung
him was the fact that so many in the UK
protested against the Iraq war.
So my argument to him was,
how can you be attacking these people?
But I'm happy,
you know,
he changed his mind.
I don't know where he is and what he's
doing now,
but that's,
you know,
that's a,
it's a small incremental step towards
peace and reconciliation.
And it was one of the first examples
that I felt sent me on the path that I'm
now on.
Yeah.
And that,
that's why I wanted to ask you about
that because I,
I love the story.
It's a beautiful story in it and it's
about what I think your whole life now
is about,
which is trying to explain all this to
people and actually get people to
change.
And I think one of the problems we're
really having here is that I see both
sides on this or however many sides do
you want to say there are.
I see everybody sort of getting
entrenched and the dialogue sort of
disappearing.
So I think that's a perfect segue.
You just coauthored a book with Sam
Harris.
I had Sam on the show a couple of weeks
ago.
Uh,
it's called Islam and the future of
tolerance.
Um,
so first off,
I think people would love to know a
little bit more about the nature of your
relationship with Sam,
how you guys came together.
Sam,
of course,
is a devout atheist.
Uh,
you're,
you're a practicing Muslim,
correct.
I don't call myself religious or devout.
I'm a Muslim,
but I wouldn't want to hold myself up as
any standard for anyone to judge the
religion by or anything else.
Well,
there you go.
So that said,
tell me a little bit about how you got
connected with Sam and what sort of
brought you two together to really go
ahead and start doing things like this.
So,
uh,
we,
I first met a few years ago when I came
to New York where I am right now to
debate a Ayaan Hirsi Ali.
And the motion of the debate was Islam
is a religion of peace.
And there's something I need to clarify
with that debate is that I've never
believed it's saying never sorry.
In my current incarnation off believing
his,
his area,
I've not believed that Islam is a
religion of war or peace.
And this is something I've been ending
of my dialogue with Sam.
I chose the side of that motion that
Islam is a religion of peace because
there was emotion and I had to choose
whether it was a religion of war or
peace and pick a side.
I think the emotion was worded
incorrectly frankly.
Um,
the,
you know,
I,
there a religion of peace,
it's just a religion and religion's are
interpreted,
um,
but nevertheless I sat on the side that
it was a religion of peace because I
logically reason in my mind that if the
majority of Muslims today aren't
jihadist or be at many,
many,
many Muslims are not liberal in the way
I would like to certainly not jihadist
terrorists.
And so if religion is what people make
it,
if Islam is what Muslims interpret it to
be,
then by definition it's a religion of
peace simply because Muslims that are by
the overwhelming majority are not
terrorists.
So I sat on that side of the debate
night.
I debated him afterwards.
We ended up in the dinner afterwards and
uh,
and Sam who happened to be there and I
hadn't mentioned before and uh,
I,
he was called upon by a ions,
will asked me a question and he asked
me,
you know,
he said,
look,
it's all good and well,
you being out there and needing to
present this view to the public about
Islam being this or that.
But,
you know,
here between us in the privacy of this,
of this dinner,
can't you just be honest with us and
tell us that,
you know,
what you really think about Islam is a
religion.
So I want immediate reaction.
I was to say to him,
are you accusing me of lying?
Um,
what do you mean?
Can I not be honest with you?
Are you implying that I wasn't honest
outside,
they're on the platform and it became a
very,
a hostile exchange which ended,
that it didn't go any further and
everyone was a bit embarrassed around
the table.
We didn't really develop beyond that
point and then we didn't speak for a
couple of years.
Um,
and,
and so then Sam reached out to me when I
think he'd watched me at the Richmond
for,
um,
when I was reunited again where they on
this time.
The good thing was,
it wasn't a debate,
it was a conversation.
And that's actually the richmond
parameter.
Thank you.
The people from the Richmond form of
watching this,
I want to thank them because the format
that they got,
the same moderator John Donvan
moderating the debate at the
intelligence squared,
a exhaust earlier on occasion.
Um,
uh,
but instead they got a on myself and
Emam Ralph who had been the,
uh,
the email or the main Manhattan mosque
and instead of having a motion to
debate,
they just said it.
We only have to have a conversation.
So that really allowed for me to be in
the middle because he was arguing Islam
as a religion of peace.
I almost arguing it's not that it's a
religion of war instead and allowed me
in the center to say,
guys,
you know,
actually I yarns got something right and
you've got something right.
And there's actually something in the
middle here.
And uh,
that,
that I think that conversation really
set the precedent for what happened with
Santa me afterwards because I think he
saw that.
I think almost really impressed with
the,
the tone that I talked with her in that
conversation.
And I was really happy with the
research,
with the way in which we,
she reciprocated my overtures to have
because I think that really laid the
foundations for what happened next.
And then Sam reached out to me and said,
hey,
can we kind of have that type of
conversation for my blog?
Because,
you know,
he interviews people on his podcast,
he publishes it on his blog.
So I said,
well,
yeah,
sure,
we,
we sort of had this,
um,
uh,
exchange over the phone and he
transcribed it.
And I said,
Sam,
this is actually really good.
I don't think you should put it on your
blog.
I actually sensed this is a book that
gets,
you know,
that could really influence a lot of
people.
Um,
and so then he approached a Harvard and,
and uh,
I called the editor in chief at Harvard,
uh,
agreed.
And uh,
that,
that's the story of the book which hits
the shelves in a week.
Yeah.
So,
so we'll talk about more about Sam in a
second.
But I think something interesting that
you said about Ian is that,
so I think a lot of your critics are a
lot of the people that are critical of
everyone on your,
your side of this is that,
that you guys all think exactly the same
thing,
but,
so I'm fascinated that.
So you and I actually don't agree on
certain elements of this.
Well,
you see,
that's the laziness and the knee jerk
reaction,
the emotional reaction,
which is born of fear,
the fear of dialogue and a fear of
actually having conversations with
people,
um,
that we may disagree with,
is that actually the best way to ignore
the consequences that dialogue can work.
It's a tiny share,
everyone with the same brush and it's
two,
in fact,
you know,
effectively slander everyone.
Um,
and that way that we are justifying to
ourselves and those who are listening to
us why dialogue isn't a good thing.
The truth is that,
um,
even after this dial this,
and there are probably many things that
he and I don't see eye to eye on him
with a on as well.
And,
uh,
but the important thing is in
recognizing that dialogue is a process.
It's not a,
uh,
you know,
you don't just snap your fingers and
somebody agrees with you.
Um,
and democracy itself,
by the way,
liberal democracies weren't born in a
day.
The reason why we use the word mature
democracies will be referred to
countries like United States.
The United Kingdom is because they've
had centuries over which time they've
matured.
And that's what the kids use.
That analogy.
That's exactly what a dialogue with
people you disagree with,
is that they hadn't matures over time.
Right?
So there's been a bunch of people you
can name them if you like.
We've talked about them a lot here and
I'm almost,
I'm almost tired of talking about them
at this point who are writing some
pretty horrific things about you,
uh,
you know,
the worst kind of slanderous stuff,
calling you names that if anyone on the
right called you,
they'd be condemned.
And,
and rightfully so,
and I'm seeing so much of this coming
from the left and these are the people
who I thought would be the one standing
up for all the things that you're
talking about here,
the words that you're talking about,
conversation,
liberalism,
all of these things,
uh,
and you're getting it from the left.
What,
what do you make about that?
So let's away from the individuals and,
and look at the movement and,
and,
you know,
the individuals at the end of the day,
they,
whatever they say about me and wherever
they are and have used a certainly one,
uh,
as bad as I was when I was a
revolutionary Islam is so I hope they
can change you're a good way.
What I believe in change and I hope that
people adapt turned into phase.
If they do change their views,
I'd be perfectly happy to continue being
friends with them.
And Reza Aslan,
who used to sit on my organization's
board in London as a member of our
advisory council and we disbanded it,
uh,
two years into a founding organization.
So it hasn't existed for about five
years.
But,
you know,
we used to,
another guy,
we invited him to London for a foot,
he's spoken at my offices in London,
acquit him.
So,
you know,
people change and I'm hoping,
and I'm hoping that we can resume of
accordion,
a form of relationship with all of these
guys.
You know,
I just think that if I can,
if I can be a go from where I was to
where I am,
I have faith in humanity.
But it is important to talk about the
concepts because that's the only way
people do change by the way is when,
as happened with me,
is when those ideas are challenged and
in a way that tries.
And it's difficult.
We're all human beings.
We all have emotions.
We will have egos,
but in a way to challenge those ideas
without making about the ego because,
but actually just really making it about
the concepts themselves.
And so what you've referred to is what
I've come to refer to as the regressive
left.
And uh,
and what I mean by the regressive left
is because they're,
you know,
not all of the people on the left wing,
progressive leftists are just like not
all Muslims are Islamists.
And so what I mean by the regressive
left Aba is this phenomenon of people on
the left wing of the debate who are,
who see between their duty,
their ideological duty to challenge,
uh,
you know,
foreign policy mistakes,
American and British foreign policy
mistakes.
So what they interpret as colonialism
and the color and they conservativism
they see it as their duty is challenged
this.
And then they see another challenge
which is theocracies and uh,
and you know,
the Islamist ideology and they,
they have come to the,
they've come to the,
uh,
to the view that you can't challenge
both of these together because if you
were to challenge his limits theocracy,
your are your supporting neoconservative
foreign policy.
So they,
in their minds,
they prioritized.
They've said,
you know,
neoconservative foreign policies and
bigger evil organized violence and chaos
in the form of military invasions is
worse than randomized nonstate act of
violence and chaos.
So we're going to go after,
if they believe they're engaged in a
war,
we're going to go after the,
this is their mindset.
We're going to go after the organized
violence.
And the reason why sometimes you see
duplicity in their statements is because
they genuinely believe it's an
ideological war.
And so it's necessary to even engage in
propaganda to defeat this bigger evil,
but we believe in which is the organized
violence and war now.
And so why I call them aggressive.
It was because in doing so,
they make alliances with some of the
most regressive,
theocratic,
fascist,
totalitarian,
barbaric,
murdering,
and justifies of murderous regimes
across the world,
right?
So,
you know,
whether it's Hezbollah terrorist
organization that's county fighting
alongside the dictator asset and,
uh,
to fight with a against the Syrian
people.
And the reason I use the example of his
mom because the man has just been
elected to the,
to the Labour party leadership in the
United Kingdom,
who's,
uh,
who's actually born on this regressive
left phenomenon has,
has been a historically has been very
close to groups such as support groups
such as his Blah [inaudible].
So that's why I'm siting in this
example.
So when was his beloved,
whether it's Hummus,
you know,
on the one hand I can see the
frustration of people who want a,
a two state solution which includes a
secure free and independent Israel and a
secure and free and independent
Palestine.
But that frustration shouldn't
legitimize,
uh,
the uh,
supporting an organization that has at
the heart of its policy,
the legitimization of targeting
civilians.
And so what's happened is when I called
the regressive is that they've allied in
there are anti colonial prioritization
with some of the most regressive
theocratic organizations that are out
there in the world.
And then,
and then,
and then they feel it,
they feel that anyone who,
uh,
who criticizes those organizations is,
is by definition with the
neoconservatives.
So they must attack them.
And that's what's going on.
And I take the view,
actually you can criticize,
I opposed the Iraq war and the invasion
of Iraq from my jail cell in Egypt.
I have never supported the invasion of
Iraq.
I've never supported a conservativism on
a member of the Liberal Democrats in the
UK.
I've never been a member of any
conservative party,
I've never been a conservative,
uh,
or,
or supporter of wars in that sense in my
life.
So,
so you can oppose those things at the
same time.
You can oppose a theocratic fascism.
We can haul two thoughts at the same
time and it's not impossible to do.
And I encourage everyone to try it.
Yeah.
I love how you wrap that together
because you're right,
it's two thoughts at the same time.
And when I talked about this,
we're Sam,
you know,
he was saying that they want to find
this nugget in you and once they find
this thing that they say you have,
not that you say you have it,
but that they say you have,
then it's somehow discounts every other
liberal principle that you have,
which is why suddenly I'm hearing from
them that they'll call Bill Maher is
suddenly a neo-con Bill Maher who has,
I think stood for every liberal
principle been against every war that I
can possibly think of.
Um,
and I have a suspicion that
unfortunately,
what these guys are doing,
I think for the reasons that you laid
out very well,
I think they're actually strengthening
the extremists on both sides,
right?
Because they are strengthening the
Islamist extremists because they're not
challenging them.
And then they're strengthening the,
uh,
the extremists because they're saying
they're making it seem like there's this
one set of ideas that can't be talked
about.
And secular people want to talk about
all ideas,
right?
Well,
if we,
if we have come to refer to this as the
voldemort effect,
you know what I mean?
It's the,
it's the Harry Potter books in which I'm
a j,
a k,
she devices really clever mechanism.
The people in the story are so fearful
of the evil of voldemort that two things
happened.
One,
they can't,
they don't read,
they don't believe ultimately is
actually alive.
They think he's dead and they refuse to
admit accept anyone that's telling them
to vote.
One still lives on.
The second is that they're so petrified,
or this photo who they believe is dead,
uh,
that they can't even name him.
So they refer to him as he who must not
be named.
Um,
so that's what I mean is the votable
effect.
And that leads to,
you know,
when you can't name something that
actually is staring at you in the face
and you're so scared of it,
but you deny exists and you don't want
to name it.
That increases the hysteria.
So,
you know,
when president trump says we must defeat
the evil ideology,
well which evil ideology,
right?
You know,
and so then you mean the average dude
that stands up in Donald Trump's rally
and says,
when are we going to deal with America's
Muslim problem?
Or Carson who says,
you know,
he doesn't want a Muslim president when
they say these things because the evil
ideology,
when they hear that word,
what they mean by that is Islam.
And by default,
every Muslim who identifies with Islam,
which is why they don't want to Muslim
president.
So what we're doing is by blurring those
lines,
we're increasing that hysteria and
actually the fee and the bigotry that
we're trying to avoid.
So what I argue is for those two
reasons,
and actually more importantly to empower
a reforming Muslim voices within Muslim
communities because the first victims of
theocratic fascism will be those Muslims
themselves.
It will be the Muslim women,
it will be the,
uh,
the minorities.
So the Yazidi women,
it will be the Coptic Christians in
Egypt,
it will be the liberal Muslims,
it'll be the apostates,
the ex Muslims,
there'll be the game Muslims and the
lesbian Muslims.
These are the ones who first suffer
under,
under the yoke of the aquatic fascism.
We need to also provide them with a
lexicon that they can deploy it in their
own internal reform debates.
So if you don't,
if you don't recognize Islam,
Islam,
what are they going to say?
Is the problem when they're having these
debates within their communities,
Islam,
the religion that's going to get them
killed immediately in the first place.
Aside from the,
you know,
the intellectual point that.
What do you mean by Islam and religion?
It's interpreted in a million different
ways.
God,
yeah.
That that's such a good handle on why
this is so difficult because we're
talking about ideas,
we're talking about people,
we're talking about religion,
we're talking about a political
movements is just so much at once.
Um,
so just to sort of re,
uh,
just to bring around this,
this part of it,
um,
in terms of dealing with these people,
the people that have been writing all
these things and all that.
How,
how personally exhausting is it for you?
Because I see and I've read,
you know,
where Sam has said,
he's not going to do anymore.
And he said to me,
even that,
then suddenly it's like he has to say
something because it's not fun being
lied about or slandered or smeared.
And,
and as I said before you and away get it
worse,
a tweet by one of these guys just this
week to you was about how he's going to
report you to the Department of Homeland
Security when you come to the United
States because he doesn't want an x
terrorist here.
I mean this is really horrible.
So how do you just deal with it on the,
on the personal level?
It's exhausting,
right?
You see,
the thing with this tweet is really
raises an interesting insight and again,
you know,
I hope this guy changes his approach to
this,
but the interesting thing this raises
is,
is a liberal guy who extensively opposes
profiling at airports,
which by the way,
I've always done,
I've always been a.
I'm a,
you can find more that I've done against
profiling then any of these voices,
if you Google Google on youtube,
there's a whole debate on that on BBC
news night,
which is the flagship news show in the
UK against the left wing Labor policy
member of parliament who also happens to
be Muslim who was advocating profiling,
uh,
five years ago.
And I was debating him on that.
So,
you know,
this is a city idea,
so I've always been against profiling.
But so was this guy who sent the tweet
you just referred to get.
What's interesting is suddenly when
somebody is breaking out of the group
thing,
think and disassociating themselves with
the tribal identity that,
that,
that we use to,
uh,
to have this us and them kind of gaining
a,
that we referred to earlier that,
you know,
you're either with the neocons,
are you with us,
uh,
and that kind of awesome them relies on
this tribal identity.
When someone breaks free from that
tribal identity,
refuses to belong here or there,
suddenly you find that it's open season,
that all the principles that we use to
actually tarnish the neocons,
the neocons who want to profile Muslims,
it's the neocons who are racist.
We're using that same racism against
those dissenting voices.
I was called a porch monkey,
right?
I was called a native informant.
I was called a Muslim by white non
Muslims in this instance,
really reputable people.
This isn't just random eggs on twitter
saying,
no,
no.
These are,
these are journeys that worked for
established,
um,
organizations with lightfoot established
blogs.
And then on top of that,
you've just mentioned somebody saying,
I hope dhs reads that department phone.
It reads your book before you come to
the states because I don't want an x
terrorists coming into the into the
United States and put aside the fact I
was never a terrorist.
That's advocating profiling by somebody
who a literally a day earlier had been
on CNN accusing Sam Harris of advocating
profiling.
Yeah,
and so,
so it's suddenly what happens is when
you break away from that group,
a kind of tribal group think it becomes
open season and that's why I said
earlier that I think what's going on
here is they genuinely believe they're
engaged in a war and so in a war,
all of these tactics become legitimate
because the objective is to win.
It's not to find the truth,
and I think that's of the problem.
That's why I think this dialogue and
this conversation is so important
because what we do is we break down that
hostility,
so I keep referring.
That's why actually it's a lesson to
myself as well.
It's so important to remain polite with
these guys because whenever they say to
me,
if I.
If I reinforce that notion that they've
somehow managed to convince themselves
that this is a war,
and if I respond in that manner,
they will double down and they will
continue to act.
This is a war and that anything is,
is,
uh,
is permissible.
So,
you know,
that's why I try and,
and deescalated and I fail sometimes,
but you know,
it's important for me to keep trying.
Yeah.
I feel the same way I,
I try as well from the little piece of
this that I'm part of and I've tried to
engage some of these people in a
respectful way and unfortunately,
you know,
as Sam as illustrated quite well,
it's hard to debate when you have your
facts and then the person you're
debating is debating what they think you
say or what they want you to say.
Not,
not what you,
what you actually say.
Um,
you know,
I think a little bit of this also is
what Bill Maher refers to as the bigotry
or the soft bigotry of low expectations.
Do you feel that,
that somehow these people,
and again I'm talking about the white
liberals in this group,
that they think because you think
differently than they want you to think
that that shows racism,
right?
You could call right now into your show
when you,
when you do your production,
uh,
an image of me talking me talking to Sam
Harris and,
and being quarter porch monkey for it.
Yeah,
I mean,
talking to Morgan Freeman now.
Now the question I ask is why?
Why would none of these guys in and they
haven't done?
So why would any of these guys not
cormier porch monkey for talking to
Morgan Freeman?
It's not call me his native informant.
No.
Call me his porch monkey.
Yet when I'm talking to a white man,
his porch monkey,
they call me his native informant.
That's the racism of low expectations.
It's the assumption is that when a brown
man is talking to a brown man,
it's a meeting of equals.
But when a brown man is talking to a
white land,
the Brown man suddenly loses all agency
and can't think for himself and his
following the white man's thoughts.
And yet,
the irony is that I don't even use that
form of identity politics to describe
people.
I don't see people as white people,
Brown people I see effectively I use,
I,
I like people to look at people as their
values.
You know,
if someone's liberal,
if someone's Islamist,
if someone's a conservative,
that's how I look at people.
Um,
because it,
it tells me where I stand with them.
It's a much more than skin color does,
but these are the people who are,
who are ostensibly anti racist,
deploying that full of racism.
And you will find that,
you know,
I tweeted the,
an image of Morgan Freeman and nice
yesterday.
I'm putting it on my facebook page.
I have not once heard any reaction from
any of this,
a regressive left phenomenon,
uh,
in,
in the sense of being cold,
his native informant or his house or his
porch monkey.
It hasn't simply hasn't happened and
that there is a best example of the
reverse racism of low expectations.
Yeah.
So I had been using the regressive left
also.
I just started using it in,
in the last few weeks.
And a few of my friends that are in this
space aren't thrilled with me because of
it,
but I think what you're exposing there
is a fatal flaw of progressivism because
they view things in the prism of
identity politics.
It's very hard to extricate someone with
a separate idea or someone that doesn't
fit the cliche and you're literally a
walking,
breathing example of that,
which is explains why you get the,
the shit that you do.
And it's important to mention at the
same time when I'm sitting there on a
tweet out that I,
um,
I was Morgan Freeman in the mosque
explaining,
you know,
having a conversation about the
difference between Islam and Islamism.
It is important to mentioned.
But at the same time I got lots of
reaction from people saying,
uh,
the difference between Islam and Islam.
Islam is in your head.
I'm actually in the same thing.
So there's also that side of the
reaction,
you know,
I'd get it from that side too.
People insisting that Islam is what they
believe it to be,
which is what are kind of in the.
And then I'm just engaged myself in a
form of apology for,
for what Islam is.
And so it's,
it's,
it's difficult to try and strike this
balance where,
um,
you know,
we need honesty in this conversation.
We need people to accept that there's a,
a problem with Islamist extremism and
there's also in fact a challenge in
dealing with,
uh,
taking Islam out of its medieval heyday,
the paradigms and the theological
paradigms that were developed in the
earlier that we simply haven't moved on
from.
And,
and actually that means that a whole
bunch of Muslims.
So the Islam is obviously don't write me
a whole bunch of traditionalist,
non Islamist conservative Muslims don't
like me because I talk about reforming
the interpretation and then a whole
bunch of anti Muslim people on the other
side who want me to apostasizes don't
write me because.
Because I say Islam can be interpreted a
and they want me to say that Islam is
evil.
Uh,
so,
you know,
you ended up getting kind of stuck in
this middle of this.
It requires a lot of patients.
Yeah.
Well,
I guess if you have a lot of people
hating,
you might be telling the truth.
How about you?
You don't need to be a believer in Islam
to concede the point,
which is the point I was making with
Sam,
who I think has since shifted in his
view and he's accepted that he's feeling
has changed somewhat on this point.
You don't need to be a believer in the
religion of Islam to concede that texts
can be interpreted.
It's not as simple as saying,
I'm going to go to a restaurant and
order a lobster and if you bring me a
chicken,
why did you bring the chicken when I
wanted a lobster?
Because it's got the menu says mobster.
You're ordering one thing that what
we're talking about is a Amandla bit
like a car manual.
When something's gone wrong in the
engine and reading the whole thing or
working out what the diagnosis is,
you know where the particular relevant
parts are,
how you put them together.
When you're talking about complex ideas
like that,
like interpreting scripture and adapting
them to the time and space,
we find ourselves in,
you know,
by definition,
it's an exercise in interpretation and
that's why even with the US
Constitution,
you've got the same document being used
as a source for pro choice and pro life
people or pro gun laws and gun
restriction people using the very same
document to make their arguments because
the dispute is over what that document
means in this day and age in the first
place.
And so you don't really need to believe
in the scripture to concede that there
is no one definitive reading of
Shakespeare.
There's no one definitive reading of the
Bible and there's no one definitive
reading of the Koran.
Yeah.
Alright.
So one more piece on this portion of all
this,
what do you make of the term
Islamophobia?
Uh,
because to me the term itself has a lot
of problems with it because I don't
think people fear Islam as in the
religion.
They fear if there,
if there is a fear.
For some people it's the actions.
They fear the actions that people are
taking in the name of the religion,
and again,
that I know that can be confusing for
people because that's the idea verse the
people,
but I do see this meme of calling
everyone in Islamophobia and it goes,
of course,
to a lot of things we've talked about so
far,
but I fear that,
that their use of that word also is
creating a real,
uh,
a real backlash to what they want to
accomplish.
Well,
the sea,
often this word is deployed to silence.
You know,
it's used to kind of muzzle the debate
when people have every right to
criticize and scrutinize and satirize
any idea whether it's Christianity,
science,
whether it's religion,
whether it's Islam,
any idea,
um,
is open to scrutiny in the patent.
That's the,
the,
the essence of progress.
It's how all societies have ended up
where they are today.
Um,
every innovator for their day was a
blast.
Fema,
Galileo questioned things that he was
called a heretic for what's considered a
heretic for theory of evolution.
And so,
um,
you know,
and even profits were heritage acts
against the old religion.
Um,
you know,
whether that's Mohammed,
Jesus,
Moses,
so at the end of the day,
if it wasn't for blast for me,
if it wasn't for,
in other words,
questioning established norms and
heresy,
we wouldn't have progress.
So to use the word Islamophobia,
to silence any scrutiny of an idea would
be to hinder this debate and the
progress that is needed in this debate.
I don't like the term for that reason
and I think it's deployed to often
against people who are simply
questioning whether the,
whether Islam needs to be reformed or
not,
or whether Islam.
Islam has a relationship to Islam,
which of course it does.
You know,
Islam.
Islam is an offshoot of Islam.
It's wrong to say it's got nothing to do
with Islam and so people don't have in
asking these questions to deal with some
very real problems in the world.
I've been called Islamophobes and that's
actually unfair.
I prefer the word anti Muslim bigot.
There is such a thing as our anti Muslim
bigotry.
There are people who like Carson,
who don't believe in a,
in perhaps don't believe in evolution,
but they also don't want Muslim
presidents of the United States.
Well,
what do you do with a neuroscientist who
doesn't believe in evolution?
Those things don't seem like they should
add up,
but it kind of indicates,
you know,
they,
they're.
So there is something about people that
have a,
they want to discriminate against people
like me because of the religion I was
born into.
Right?
That,
that's,
that's anti Muslim bigotry,
but that's very different to
scrutinizing the idea and that's why I
developed this maximum,
which again,
I'm the dialogue with Sam and that isn't
no idea,
uh,
should be or is ever above scrutiny.
No idea is above screws and even though
people have been a dignity.
And I think that really nicely
summarizes where we should stand on this
debate.
Yeah.
That's actually a great segue for my
next question,
which is,
what has the reaction from just sort of
the mainstream Muslim community in
England been to you?
Because when I,
even when I tweeted out that we were
going to sit down and do this,
the majority of it was positive.
Now obviously we have a certain amount
of people that follow both of us and
know what we think about things that
enjoy what we do.
So that's expected.
But I did get some people that said,
oh,
you know,
it was,
it was this porch monkey mentality,
oh,
he's just doing this for,
for money and affection of white people.
And a lot of that,
what I think is pure nonsense.
But what,
what about the mainstream Muslim
community,
uh,
that you're around every day?
Well,
look,
you know,
mainstream Muslims on Islamists,
they are conservative,
but they're not Islamists and there's
certainly not jihadists.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
while they're not going to do,
even if they disagreed with me,
is they're not gonna,
you know,
they're not going to basically attack me
for it or,
or launch into a tirade at home with
them even if they disagreed.
Now I'm,
I'm very realistic about where I stand
among my own religious communities.
And that's because if I had just
restricted myself to challenging
Islamism,
I probably would have had the support of
the other welding majority,
the mainstream of Muslims,
but the other alarming mainstream also
happened to be in social and religious
matters,
conservative with a small seat.
And I challenged that to I call for
reform in our approach and
interpretation of the scripture.
I'm a liberal socially,
uh,
as well as politically and um,
and I mentioned I'm a member of the
Liberal Democrats in the United Kingdom,
which is the centrist party there.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I have very openly supported a lot of
social reform on these issues.
And I think that,
you know,
we have some acid Quilliam who advocated
for the reconciliation of evolution,
Islamic create these granite creed that
was incredibly controversial when he did
something,
he was kicked out of his mosque,
uh,
for that.
And that's not an Islamic mosque,
it's a conservative mosque.
And so the reason that,
that,
um,
that you will sense a lot of backlash,
it's because we take on the twin
challenges of,
uh,
wanting to again,
another sort of maximum is that what we
want to do is that Islam is a,
must be intellectually terminated,
uh,
whereas Islam needs to be reformed.
But that's the twin challenge that faces
us.
And it means that obviously because no
change is seamless,
all change is painful.
A lot of people get upset when they kind
of hear some of the things we say,
but that's the nature of change.
I mean,
you know,
that's how society has changed.
It's,
it's,
it's normal.
Yeah.
I know you might be slightly hesitant to
talk about this,
but can I ask you just in terms of your
own personal safety,
I'm sure you are.
You are threatened.
I know that,
that a lot of the other people in this
from bill to Sam,
too many others have a certain amount of
threats that they deal with from,
from all fronts.
By the way,
you know,
I think from someone like Sam,
it comes from people from radical
Christians too.
So I don't even,
I don't even want to make this about
Islam or Muslims particularly,
uh,
but people I think need to understand
that you put yourself at great risk to
talk about the things that you're
talking about,
right?
Yeah.
I don't want to dwell on this,
but it's not exactly the safest
occupation in the world.
So there's a lot going on in,
in England politically right now in
Jeremy Corbyn,
who you mentioned earlier,
is now head of the Labor Party.
What's the general sense of the
political atmosphere in England right
now?
Because in America we get very,
very little.
Even if I just flick on BBC for a
second,
I mean we have very,
very little of what's going on with,
with basically our biggest ally in the
world.
Yeah.
It's interesting because we are facing
the inlaws on what's happening here with
the phenomenon of the rise of Donald
trump.
We've got Jeremy Corbyn who is populist
in the way that trump is on the left
wing of politics and it's the same
discourse.
And actually that's why you have the
horse horseshoe theory of politics.
You know that actually ultimately you're
left and right.
They come and they end up when they go
to the extreme,
that meeting in the middle anyway.
Yeah,
Mussolini's Fascist,
and I'm not calling a fascist by any
means,
but mostly in his fascism was a left
wing phenomenon that emerged into
totalitarian fascism.
So they ended up meeting.
And the reason that,
so if you look at corbion and trump,
what they both have in common is they're
antiestablishment approach.
Um,
is that a total disdain for politics and
the way that things have been going on?
Um,
they,
they want to change the status quo,
that playing on popular anger,
which in many instances is there for
legitimate reasons.
But in other instances it's playing up
the identity politics.
They identify the other.
So in trump's case,
the Mexicans and the wall that the city
idea of building a wall that he wants,
you know,
identifying the other and allying with
some unsavory people to achieve that.
It's all part of the parcel of,
of the politics of our,
of our times and across Europe were
witnessing this phenomenon with the rise
of far right populist parties.
And in Greece we had golden dawn,
now we got series series a,
which is a far left populist party.
And uh,
in Scotland we had the Scottish
nationalists who wanted to break away
from the United Kingdom and the other
for them where the English.
So,
um,
because for whatever reason people are
feeling particularly vulnerable and
insecure,
they are rallying around identity
politics and defining themselves against
somebody else.
And I think that's a particularly,
it's a very unhelpful,
unhealthy way to engage in politics and
it leads to more division,
which is what we see playing out across
a lot.
Yeah,
not only do we see it playing out across
the world,
but now you know,
we have this massive refugee crisis
which you guys in Europe or are having
to deal with much more than we are in
the states now.
Europe already has a huge problem with
integrating their immigrants as a
general rule a,
especially in Muslim.
Right?
So what,
what do you make of what England or what
the rest of the EU should be doing or
can be doing with the refugee situation?
I think the important thing is
integration.
I would caution people and they will be
in the United Kingdom.
We are overdue isis attack.
So not if,
but when Isis chooses and decides it's
capable of striking in the UK,
I would urge people not to blame the
refugees.
These are people who are,
uh,
in some cases who have fought isis in
Syria and Iraq and then a flat since
then or in other cases were fleeing for
their lives because they disagree with
everything that Isis is doing.
Of course among them there may be one or
two fighters and uh,
but that's neither here nor there
because 1000 born and raised British
citizens of concert joined isis anyway.
So they're,
they're,
they're finding it easy enough to
recruit from UK born citizens,
let alone having to sneak them in with
refugees.
So if there are attacks,
I would urge people not to blame these
poor desperate refugees who need our
help.
And our sympathy and our understanding
and what I would consider what I would
say is important to consider for
governments.
On the other hand,
is not to repeat the,
is when,
what you mentioned integration wasn't
seen as important.
And so what we ended up developing in
Europe and in Britain,
I can speak to what he's self segregated
communities that didn't mix with one
another and they,
they grew up,
you know,
it's possible in 2015 to be born and
raised in London as a Muslim teenager
and not have a single mom,
Muslim friend,
nor a single friend from the opposite
sex.
And I just think that's not a healthy
psychological state to be in.
So I would encourage governments to have
really,
really robust and strong integration
policies.
Yeah.
Uh,
do you think that that's even possible
because they're already dealing with the
integration problem that exists?
It seems to me that the conversation has
been dumbed down to the point where if
you say anything,
if you were to say,
well we shouldn't bring in more refugees
right now that people would immediately
call you racist,
which the truth probably is somewhere
between,
you know,
there's obviously a certain amount of
people that are going to be xenophobic
no matter what.
And then there are also some legitimate
concerns about what the,
what this can do to societies.
But we so rarely have this conversation,
right?
Yeah.
And it's,
you know,
at the end of the day I'm,
the immigration conversation is a bit
like the Islam isn't conversation then
it's immediately shot down and
accusations of bigotry.
The first,
you know,
a lead costs,
if you like,
of those who want to shut that
conversation down.
It is important that these conversations
are in fact thrown open in the recent
history,
the political history of the United
Kingdom.
We've seen the consequences of not
having these conversations because when
these debates were shut down by the,
the,
the mainstream parties.
What happened as a result is the rise of
a two groups.
One is street protest movement and the
other political party,
the Ukip United Kingdom Independence
Party that wants to break away from the
union and monster and all immigration.
That party,
which,
uh,
which started taking a chunk out of a
conservative support base arose at
lightening speed in the UK.
How do you,
by Nigel farage,
precisely because the main political
parties didn't want to talk about
racism.
And so,
uh,
an uglier version of that conversation
happened on the outside,
on the fringes of the mainstream because
we didn't want to talk about it.
And the other thing that happened was
the rise of the English Defense League,
the EDL.
So,
uh,
what have been Europe's largest street
protest movement.
I began organizing rallies and
demonstrations up and down the country
because conversation about Islam,
Islam.
So what I advocate and the reason why
I'm so a,
so a so heavily for having these
conversations is we don't have them in
the mainstream in a responsible way.
The fringes,
we'll have them in an irresponsible way.
And that's the danger of the voldemort
effect that I refer to.
And that's very much what I'm trying to
do with this show,
which is why I'm going to have people
from all over the political spectrum
here because we need,
we need these conversations.
So just one more thing on the refugee
thing.
What do you make of the Arab countries
that basically aren't taking in their
brothers?
I mean,
I think Saudi Arabia has led in maybe 30
families or something.
All these countries we're seeing Egypt's
not letting anyone in Turkey has done a
lot.
Turkey's not in our country but all but
all of these countries that are doing
this.
What do you make of that?
So,
uh,
to,
to we have a caveat.
Here's the Gulf Arab countries that had
let in zero refugees whereas Jordan,
Lebanon,
uh,
and,
and these surrounding countries that
aren't Gulf Arabs have millions of
refugees.
And so there is that distinction to be
made.
Jordan is overflowing with refugee camps
and tents and so on.
But the Gulf Arabs,
uh,
you know,
the Emirates,
Saudi Arabia,
these countries,
Kuwait,
they,
uh,
they think that actually they think that
their responsibilities,
I've been met simply by providing funds
to the refugee camps.
And I think that's a particularly
interesting point there too,
to look at it as to the,
uh,
just with like,
just as with the Syria conflict,
there are certain responsibilities that
the regional powers have to deal with
conflict in their own back gardens and
in their own region.
And unfortunately that hasn't been
happening.
On the one hand,
we complain when the international
community led by the United States of
America intervenes and you're on the
other hand when,
when no intervention is forthcoming,
we complain because we're saying that no
one cares about all the women and
children,
innocent men who are dying.
And actually the only way around this is
to say,
okay,
if you don't want international
intervention,
then take responsibility for your own
region and uh,
and intervene yourselves.
And that applies to refugees and it
applies to the war in Syria and dealing
with that through political and
diplomatic and military needs.
And I,
I'm,
you know,
I'm very critical.
Unfortunately I don't think these Gulf
countries have been doing even nearly
enough regard.
And by the way,
I don't want to just blame the Gulf
countries or any of the Arab states
because we
just saw at the UN in these last couple
of days,
there seems to be now be this new
alliance between Iraq and Iran and
Russia.
And again,
as to what you just said,
the more the US pulls out,
it seems as though the worse it gets.
And every time we go in,
we seem to make it worse,
so,
so there are no easy answers here I
think is the,
is the ultimate conclusion.
Um,
so I,
I have one more thing for you because
I've been trying to end all my
interviews on,
on some sort of feeling of hope and
actually you've done a nice job of
giving us some hope that this whole way
through.
But I really sensed that there has been
over the last couple of months a real
secular awakening.
I sense it in,
in the response I'm getting to the
videos,
the facebook messages.
People are sending me emails,
the tweets,
the whole thing that people that secular
people that want to base their values on
humanism and not on,
you know,
magical sky gods and all of that stuff
that they're really waking up.
And I,
I think you've had a part to do with it.
I think Sam,
I think many other people do you sense
that too?
Please tell me you do or I'm in a lot of
trouble.
I said it's particularly that more
voices that I call them minorities
within the minority,
people on the left that we've spoken
about earlier.
They traditional care about the minority
communities,
but actually I'd say to them that if
they really worth their salt,
if they really want to test their metal,
what they should be caring about.
Other minorities within those minority
communities,
the gay Muslims,
the lesbian Muslims,
the Muslims,
the,
the liberal Muslim,
a Muslims and the minorities such as the
Christians in Egypt of the CDS in Iraq.
So those minorities within minority
communities.
I since have been rallying and waking up
and galvanizing.
I think I sense more and more Muslim
voices coming out to speak against not
just Islam,
Islam from also a Islamic religious
conservatism and we get messages every
single day.
We get people asking to join our
organization to help us to work with us.
And I think that's really fantastic
because if we're going to really defeat
at the scourge of theocratic fascism and
if we're going to help reform the way in
which Islam is interpreted the today and
those voices are really the crucial
voices that we need to hear from.
Yeah.
Well you've been a huge part of that.
So I thank you for taking some time off
while you're in New York.
Your book with Sam,
Islam in the future of tolerance is
already sold out.
The preorders are already sold out on
Amazon.
It's coming out way.
It's coming out in a couple of days in
the bookstores,
right?
Yeah.
It will hit the bookstores very soon and
then everyone will be able to get a copy
and then actually after that the kindle
version will come out to a.
There is a kindle version coming out,
but it will come out after the pets.
A hardback version.
Here's the bookshelves.
All right,
well I'm,
I'm really glad that we got a chance to
do this.
Almost face to face.
We can see each other but.
But one day we'll be able to have a
beer.
And do it for real and good luck with
all your work.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.